今天的行情的感覺
應該是比較差一些線
盯著手機排面
一百九十公分的巨人傑
對臺股趨勢自有一套見解
身為異級散戶的他
為了將新書版稅捐給家福
終於露出廬山真面目
更分享獨門投資新法
大部分的新手可能會很重點在於
我要怎麼樣去停損出場
但這個句話的前提會是
你必須知道你為什麼進場
進場的理由消失就停損
年僅三十一歲的巨人傑
十七歲就進入股市 二十四歲政大統計研究所
畢業後成了全職台股交易員
八年級生的他進入股市
已超過十四年 每天看盤盯住十一面螢幕
其實一開始智人節本金僅一萬元
只買得起當時一張總價不到一萬的友達
如今累計成交量達五千億
朋友邀約我去吃大餐
那一餐可能五六百塊
那五六百塊我可以練習兩天那我多了兩天的經驗擁有熱血 交易魂 幾乎犧牲娛樂和睡眠看看他在瘋狂交易階段的作息表早上七點起床
看財經新聞
到八點半開始交易台股
吃完午餐後
下午兩點四十五分
開始交易歐洲股市
享用完晚餐後
晚間八點開始盯著
美國經濟數據
交易台紙期美股
直到凌晨四點才睡覺
不過財經專家也是緊
一般民眾也因為看到成功案例
就一股腦進場投資
專家也提醒
一旦發生違約交割
未來不但無法在證券行開戶
在銀行的個人信用
也會破產
投資前還是要停看聽
TV的新聞
周日峰劉瑞宣
台北這麼的
TVBS大運動家
運動迷一起競技的殿堂
馬上下載
跟中華隊一起All Win